bonjour à tous la série déco vient
récemment de sortir et le MCU a été en
quelque sorte chamboulé bien évidemment
la série chcho amène son lot
d'information et de nouveautés pour les
futures productions de l'univers
cinématographique mais si comme je viens
de vous le dire le MCU a été entre
guillemets chamboulé c'est parce
qu'additionné à ce contenu Marvel a
enfin rendu canon c'est-à-dire
officialisé comme faisant partie de son
univers la série
d'ardeville ainsi que d'autres contenus
qui étaient anciennement sur Netflix
c'est un véritable revirement car vous
le saviez Marvel a prévu prochainement
une série nommée dardeville bornegen et
jusqu'ici elle était considéré comme un
soft reboot du contenu Netflix du style
comme toujours c'est un univers
alternatif nous allons avec born gen
vous proposer notre propre dardeville
100 % Disney alors je sais bien qu'il y
avait de nombreuses références à
l'univers développé sur Netflix avec le
retour de Charlie Cox en mat mordock
lui-même dans sheulk Spider-Man Noe home
ou plus récemment echo il y avait aussi
la présence de Wilson Fisk dans Hawy et
du coup dans la série echo aussi mais
voilà malgré tout ça ce n'était pas
officialisé comme faisant partie du même
monde le multivers peut nous proposer
des réalités vraiment similaires à la
anologie sacrée que nous suivons donc
c'était la bonne excuse si Marvel et
Disney souhaitaent vraiment se séparer
du contenu Netflix cependant ce n'est
plus le cas et cela change pas mal de
choses en plus de nous poser certaines
questions et il est là le sujet de la
vidéo j'aimerais que l'on parle lor
j'aimerais que l'on parle dardeville
bornegen et plus exactement de tous les
petits nom dit du coup liés à
l'officialisation de dardeville dans le
MCU néanmoins spoiler alerte dans la
vidéo il va falloir que je spoile au
moins les trois saisons de darteville et
bien évidemment les récentes série
Disney plus comme chcho pour pouvoir
traiter le sujet si vous n'avez pas vu
d'ardville je vous conseille grandement
la série qui est sans hésiter l'une des
meilleures séries Marvel jamais
produites sur ce ne tardons pas et
attaquons le
sujet bon déjà je pense que l'une des
choses les plus importantes à faire
c'est de voir chronologiquement ce qu'il
se passe dardeville commence
officiellement en 2015 sa saison 2 se
déroule en 2016 et son grand final la
saison 3 se passe et se termine en 2017
à ce moment-là un accord est passé entre
Matt Murdock et Wilson Fisk désormais au
courant de l'identité de dardeville et
de qui sont ses proches soit Karen page
et fogy Nelson Matt fait promettre à
kingping de se faire faire
définitivement arrêter et de rester en
prison tout en laissant les proches de
Murdock tranquilles et de ne jamais
révéler l'identité de dardeville sinon
Matt fera tout pour faire arrêter
Vanessa Fisk la récente épouse de Wilson
pour qu'elle passe sa vie en prison
Wilson est alors arrêté Murdock relance
son cabinet avec ses deux amis et voilà
où nous en sommes à la fin de dardeville
sauf qu'avec l'officialisation bah voilà
vous savez ce qu' va se passer en 2018
l'arrivée de Thanos dans Infinity War et
le fameux snap qui va effacer la moitié
de l'existence et ce pendant 5 longues
années avant que les événements
d'Avengers game émergent et c'est là que
les zones d'ombre commencent et on
espère avoir des réponses sur tout ça
dans le futur dardeville et Wilson ont
survécu au snap de Thanos et comment on
le sait et bien par le biais de la série
echo qui elle aussi a survécu est témoin
de la mort de son père de la main du
renine ou renin si vous préférez renine
qui est l'identité secrète d'okai
pendant l'éclipse car suite à la
disparition de sa famille il s'était de
nouveau tourneré vers ce qu'il savait
faire tuer être une arme et plus
précisément il s'est concentré sur les
gangs ou autres mafia qui ont survécu au
claquement de doigt de
Thanos
juste après la mort du père de Maya Fisk
est intervenu pour empêcher sa protégée
de se faire arrêter par la police de New
York à ce moment précis son plan de
prendre véritablement le contrôle de la
mafia en survette grâce au ronine en
plus de faire plonger définitivement
Maya sous son contrôle se met en marche
et suite à ça Maya va commencer à
travailler pour Wilson et c'est là où
elle va affronter dardeville dans son
célèbre costume rouge et tout ça bien
évidemment cela se déroule durant
l'éclipse mais en plus de savoir que
Wilson et dardaville ont survécu au snap
il y a des éléments très intriguants
tout simplement pour commencer Fisk
n'est plus en prison donc l'accord qu'il
avait avec Matt Murdock n'a pas été
respecté en plus de cela comme nous le
montre echo et la série haokai il a de
nouveau des policiers sous sa coupe ou
du moins il craigne de nouveau le
Kingpin Wilson a également de nouveau un
appartement dans New York il a de
nouveau des moyens et il a réussi même à
prendre le contrôle d'une mafia celle en
survêtement et s'est servi pendant des
années d'éanor Bishop alors endetté
auprès de Fisk à cause de son mari il
s'est servi de son entreprise Bishop
security pour garder dans l'ombre ses
activités de blanchiment d'argent grâce
à la société dite écran slone limited
comment un tel revirement a pu se
produire Wilson s'est de nouveau bâti un
empire et il est bien loin quand même de
la fin de d'ardville saison 3 en réalité
pour moi la seule raison qui puisse
expliquer tout ça c'est Vanessa fisque
en fait tout l'accord entre mat et
Wilson repose sur la liberté de Vanessa
elle symbolise une force pour Kingpin
mais elle est surtout la plus grande
faiblesse de l'antagoniste alors qu'il
contrôle la plupart des activités
criminelle de New York dans la saison 1
Wilson après sa rencontre avec Vanessa
va commencer petit à petit à faire des
erreurs au point que ses collaborateurs
du crime vont tenter de la tuer pour que
Wilson redevienne le brillant maître de
la pègre qu'il était avec l'amour Wilson
a désormais une faiblesse quelqu'un pour
qui il s'inquiète à qui il tient et il y
a d'ailleurs une réplique forte du
personnage qui traduit bien tout ce que
je suis en train de vous
dire
et c'est ce qu'il se passe à la fin de
la saison 3 de dardeville mat se sert de
Vanessa comme cette fameuse prison de
l'amour et c'est ce qui va permettre de
faire tomber Wilson néanmoins si fis est
sorti de prison et a réussi à
reconstruire petit à petit un empire au
sein de New York jusqu'à même devenir
maire prochainement et bien je pense que
c'est parce qu'il est possiblement
arrivé quelque chose à Vanessa étant
donné qu'il a recommencé ses activités
peu de temps après le snap de Thanos
comme le montre la série echo ou même
okai il se pourrait que Vanessa est
quant à elle disparu à cause du
claquement de doigt si Vanessa n'est
plus aucune raison de respecter l'accord
avec dardeville mais pour aller encore
plus loin je dirais que Wilson et ayant
désormais goûté à l'amour si je puis
dire a retranscrit son besoin d'aimer
quelqu'un sur Maya dont il est devenu
l'oncle de par sa relation avec William
Lopez le père d'cho et c'est durant
l'éclipse une fois le père de Maya tué
par ronine guidé par Wilson que les deux
protagonistes vont véritablement se
rapprocher c'est bizarrement juste après
le snap même si bon voilà il se
connaissait déjà pas mal avant après je
sais qu'il y a une autre interrogation
liée à ça qui doit être mentionné c'est
que bien évidemment en 2023 les gens qui
ont été effacés par le snap ont été
ramené donc naturellement si Vanessa a
été effacée par le snap elle est bien
revenue en 2023 du coup et d'ailleurs
nous savons qu'actuellement à partir des
récentes informations liées à dardeville
bornugen le personnage de Vanessa sera
dans la série et sera même recast
c'est-à-dire qu'elle sera jouée par une
autre actrice bon on ne peut rien
affirmer vous le savez nous sommes
simplement dans de l'analyse dans du
raisonnement de la théorie si je puis
dire mais il se pourrait qu'il y ait
d'autres explications pour répondre à la
situation liée à Wilson Vanessa et Matt
Murdock en fait je pense qu'il ne faut
pas oublier qu'à la base Born Again
devait être un soft reboot par exemple
jusqu'à très récemment Karen et fogy ne
devaient pas apparaître dans la série il
devait même mourir h écran ça pour moi
c'est dramatique heureusement qu'ils
sont revenus sur cette décision et le
truc c'est que Marvel a appliqué cette
idée depuis un long moment avant de
faire ce virage depuis la série echo du
coup avec cette idéologie nous avons eu
un Wilson qui s'est reconstruit dans la
série haokai hors de sa prison de
nouveau leader d'une mafia et cetera et
cetera il se pourrait donc que Marvel
est fait un choix particulier concernant
Vanessa c'était quant à elle
contrairement à Karen et fogy de la tuer
en fait cela fait partie des comics
Vanessa au terme de son histoire sera
touché par une maladie qui va l'emporter
il est donc tout à fait possible
également que cette dernière n'ait pas
été touchée par le snap mais tout comme
Maria Rambo la mère de Monica elle
aurait été emportée par la maladie et ce
qui expliquerait pourquoi Wilson est de
retour surtout que il y a un moment dans
écho qui me trigger un petit peu qui me
titille c'est ce passage-là
au départ je me suis dit qu'il parlait
de James Wesley son second et plus
fidèle ami mais ce n'est pas impossible
que Wilson parle de Vanessa et vu que
nous avons besoin de réponse concernant
la période de l'éclipse nous avons
besoin de savoir ce qu'il s'est passé
pour Wilson et dardeville durant ces 5
ans il y a des chances également que le
retour de Vanessa à l'écran soit
simplement pour des flashback pour
raconter le passé c'est une possibilité
dans tous les cas comme le montre la fin
d'cho nous nous tournons désormais vers
l'adaptation de Wilson Fisk en tant que
maire de New York et personnellement je
suis très content car cela peut vraiment
annoncer du lourd et sur tous les plans
Fisk en tant que maire de New York déjà
c'est un gros morceau des comics bien
évidemment étant donné sa relation
compliquée avec dardeville avec le N et
encore plus récemment avec Kate Bishop
ou même okai il est sûr que comme il l'a
fait sur papier Wilson va nous amener
une certaine politique antiuper-héros
les temps ont quand même changé depuis
Avengers endgame et l'image des
super-héros a été plusieurs fois
fragilisée notamment depuis civil war en
soit dardeville reste tout de même une
entité clivante par rapport à tous les
événements de la série pareil pour le
Punisher qui est désormais lui aussi
aussi canon Spider-Man même si tout le
monde a oublié que c'est Peter Parker
qui l'incarne il reste tout de même aux
yeux des gens le meurtrier de Mystério
et il ne faut pas oublier les autres
complications amenées par les flags
Smashers qui avaient le sérum de super
soldat dans Falcon et le soldat de
l'hiver nous aurons très certainement
aussi les mêmes problématiques liées
cette fois-ci à Hulk très prochainement
sans oublier évidemment tout le conflit
politique lié au scrull bref en plus de
tout cela le plus intéressant reste
quand même la nouvelle puissance que va
acquérir Wilson Fisk par le biais de ce
nouveau titre là on ne parle plus
seulement de HS kitchen mais de la ville
de New York en entier en tant que maire
Wilson aura les pleins pouvoirs il aura
toute la ville sous son contrôle
notamment les policiers dans sa
globalité sans parler évidemment de
toute la père qui se rajoute à ça mais
avec un titre aussi important celui
d'être le maire de New York c'est un
excellent moi moyen de se rapprocher du
gouvernement des États-Unis et donc de
Tadeus Thunderbolt Ross qui si les plans
reste toujours inchangé devrait
certainement incarner le nouveau
président des États-Unis il ne faut pas
oublier non plus que Fisk commence
également à avoir accès à de la
technologie Stark ou du moins liée aux
Avengers nous en avions déjà parlé à
l'époque mais le damage control que nous
voyons très régulièrement dans le MCU
est lié justement à la G question de la
technologie extraterrestre présente sur
terre mais également celle des Avengers
qui commence petit à petit à se balader
au sein des rues et du pays le cachœil
de Wilson ainsi que l'équipement lui
permettant de communiquer avec Maya
proviennent à très grande chance des
travaux de Stark Industries ou du QG des
Avengers j'aime le rappeler mais dans
les comics le damage control bien que ça
soit avant tout lié à Tony Stark et bien
c'est une société qui est quand même
dirigé secrètement aussi par Fisk et là
en tant que maire de New York c'est le
moyen d'avoir accès totalement à tout ça
tout en sortant de l'ombre le damage
contrôle dans No home a perquisitionné
les travaux de Stark Industries enfin si
nous retournons sur le cas de dardeville
ce qui devrait être vraiment intéressant
c'est que la prochaine montée en
puissance de Wilson Fisk en tant que
maire de New York traduit complètement
l'échec de Matt Murdock et la R
que son ennemi juré est pleinement
reconstruit et de
retour si Vanessa n'est plus il n'existe
plus aucun moyen de pression pour
Murdock afin de faire plier Wilson Fisk
par conséquent Wilson a de quoi
désormais menacer d'ardville il connaî
son identité il sait pour et fogy mat
serait définitivement perdant dans cette
histoire actuellement je pense que si
Fisk n'a toujours pas révélé l'identité
de ma c'est parce que bien évidemment il
avait besoin de se la jouer discret et
surtout c'est une information qui est
vraiment très très utile et qui va lui
servir ce n'est pas sûr que Mat était au
courant de la reconstruction de Wilson
et ce dernier désirait rester dans
l'ombre mais surtout il y a moyen je
pense aussi que Marvel applique ce qu'
s'est passé dans les x Wilson là-bas en
tant que maire va élire mat Murdock
l'avocat omnubilé par le King pin qui a
réussi à l'envoyer en prison en tant que
mère adjoint afin de lui donner
l'illusion qu'il pourra avec ce rôle
arrêter fisque alors qu'en réalité Fisk
a fait ça pour le garder près de lui et
l'occuper pour qu'il ne puisse plus agir
en plus d'avoir du coup tous les yeux
New Yorkais toujours rivés sur ma bon je
ne suis pas sûr que Marvel fera de
Matthew le maire adjoint dans le MCU
néanmoins il est clair que Fisk se
servira des informations et des amis de
mat pour le mettre à mal ça c'est sûr
comme il sait si bien le faire il
pourrait dans un but politique obliger
dardeville à ternir sa propre image ce
qui permettra globalement de ternir
encore plus l'image des super-héros il
se pourrait carrément que Fisk utilise
même mat pour sa campagne électorale et
il faudrait aussi gérer le cas de Buzy
Buzy dans les comics ici adapté en tant
que Benjamin Po deexter et bon c'est
quand même le point final de la série de
la fin de la saison 3 en vrai il y a
deux éléments importants que nous
pouvons souligner le concernant déjà
point Dexter à la fin de la série
devient véritablement ce qu'il est censé
devenir dans les comics tout comme sur
papier sa colonne est brisée et point
Dexter sera ramené par des criminels
japonais qui injecteront du métal dans
ses EOS afin de le rendre indestructible
la véritable menace
poexter/bulsay est donc en route mais
surtout le plus intéressant c'est que
c'est un personnage qui colle
parfaitement à l'idéologie Thunderbolts
et je vous le mets dans le 1000 il a
fait partie de l'équipe dans les comics
personnellement je pense que c'est une
direction tout à fait logique et
possible pour le personnage dans le
futur si Marvel décide de miser un peu
dessus et voilà on a dit pas mal de
choses en vrai hein on a on a débité et
je pense qu'on va s'arrêter ici pour le
moment concernant cette vidéo je suis
très content de vous avoir parlé de
d'ardeville et de Kingpin ce sont
vraiment deux personnages très
intéressant et complet et là avec leur
grand retour et l'officialisation de la
série on commence petit à petit à se
tourner vers quelque chose de très stylé
je pense pour le MCU nous allons avoir
du contenu un petit peu plus terra terre
à l'échelle d'une ville et en général
c'est toujours des moments très
marquants très iconiques et on ne va pas
se mentir mais c'est quand même plus
facile à gérer et cela permet d'amener
d'autres enjeux que nous ne pourrions
pas voir dans des enjeux justement
cosmiques ou multiversel je ne sais pas
ce que vous vous en pensez mais
personnellement j'ai très hâte n'hésitez
pas du coup à me faire savoir tout ça en
commentaire si la vidéo vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit pouce
bleu bien évidemment n'oubliez pas non
plus de vous abonner j'attends de lire
vos commentaires et voilà sur ce c'était
argoroc allez ciao tout le
[Musique]
monde